back here in the u.s in texas the state
legislature is set to vote
this week on two restrictive voting
bills the legislation moved forward
yesterday after
a heated debate critics say the measures
unfairly harm
black voters mireia via real has more
from austin
democratic house representative aaron
zweiner believes the push for tighter
voting restrictions
is based on fear why do you think this
has become such
a big deal during this session texans
are still struggling in the wake of
covid
we've have severe learning disruptions
for our students and not a good plan to
correct that
and we have trouble even keeping the
lights on so i think they are deathly
afraid
that texans are about to figure out that
they have better options
and are doing everything they can to
cling on to power bills
filed by republican state senators would
include
new id requirements for people voting by
mail
ban 24 hour voting and drive-through
voting sites
and increase criminal penalties for
election officials or people assisting
voters
but what we see today is greater
suppression
in legislation to provide less access to
the polls
hundreds of texans from across the state
flocked to the capitol over the weekend
and gave public testimonies in marathon
all-night hearings
texas already has some of the most
restrictive voting laws in the country
and this is going to create even more
hurdles to people voting
it's a common sense reform bill that's
going to help every texan vote
republican state senator brian hughes
wrote the senate bill
democrats will say this is more about
the idea that the election was stolen
back in november
and that these restrictions are being
put in place to punish voters
moving forward senate bill 1 is about
protecting voters from folks who are
trying to steal their votes from ballot
harvesters
from unscrupulous workers folks who are
trying to influence coerce
mislead literally steal ballots that
happens
still happens
democrats were able to block a similar
set of restrictive bills earlier this
year by staging a walkout they say they
are considering that again as well as
other options but the lieutenant
governor here in texas says
if that happens he will step in and make
sure he protects the legislative process
anthony maria thank you